يعني قبل منتصف
الليل شنه الشنه الطائرات اسرائيليه غارات
جويه مؤلفه من رشاقات
ومجموعات من الصواريخ استهدفت
موقعين في
محافظه حلب الموقع الاول كان في منطقه
مطاري حلب الدولي والنيرب
العسكري مما تسبب بحدوث اضرار ماديه في
مطار النيرب العسكري ومطار حلب الدولي
وخروج مطار حلب الدولي عن الخدمه مؤقتا
جراء استهداف
مدرج المطار باحد الغارات ايضا الموقع
الاخر المستهدف هو في
بلده او في منطقه السيره بريف حلب حيث رصد
سقوط عده صواريخ بالقرب من معامل
في المنطقه طبعا
الاعلام الرسمي تحدث عن عن خروج مطار حلب
الدولي عن الخدمه وتحدث عن مقتل جندي
واصابه شبعه اخرين بجروح بينهم مدنيين
اثنين طبعا شده الغارات الجويه وشده
الانفجارات التي
استهدفت منطقه مطاري حلب الدولي والنيرب
العسكري تسببت بحدوث اضرار بسيطه في
منازل المدنيين في عده مناطق منها النيرب
ومخيم النيرب وجبريل مما ادى لوصول عدد من
المصابين
بشظايا بسيطه وجروح جراء انكسار الزجاج في
هذه المناطق نتيجه شده هذه
الضربات طبعا
انفجارات متتاليه ثلاث الغارات الجويه
ومصادر محليه تحدثت عن اشتعال مستودع
للاسلحه والذخائر في هذه المنطقه وهنا
اتحدث عن منطقه مطاري حلب الدولي والنيرب
العسكري لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
وتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات